Напівпорожні будинки в Авдіївці.
За квартирами сусідів Ольга Кійко
доглядає майже два роки.
Після евакуації в 2015-ому році
більше нікуди виїжджати не хоче.
Втомилася і від війни, і від очікування миру.
До планів Києва щодо зміни статусу АТО має неоднозначне ставлення.
Якщо вони хочуть йти в наступ, то дай Боже!
А якщо хочуть знов стояти на місці, то навіщо воно потрібно?
Хай тоді АТО залишається.
Введення на лінії розмежування військового стану
передача функцій контролю за ситуацією від СБУ військовим.
Іншого варіанту донецький губернатор Павло Жебрівський не бачить.
На його думку,
треба запровадити і особливий режим функціонування місцевих комендатур,
аби вони нарешті отримали повноваження для термінового відновлення інфраструктури.
Обстріляли будинки, лікарні.
І я по всім процедурам, як у Тернопільській області,
повинен проводити по системі "Прозоро",
вибирати проект та, потім проектант буде робити проект,
потім по системі "Прозоро" повинен обирати підрядника.
Тільки після цього маю відбудовувати.
Це безтяма і це нереально.
Я думаю, що було б правильно  змінити формат.
Яким є план щодо деокупації та
реінтеграції непідконтрольних територій,
губернатор детально не знає.
Зміст законопроекту поки не оприлюднили.
Інтриги навколо змісту законопроекту
можуть дестабілізувати ситуацію в прифронтових районах,
попереджають громадські активісти.
Якщо мається на меті повернення до цього
- реінтеграція, щоб зробити пом’якшення для населення,
щоб люди не боялися, щоб було примирення,
щоб було визволення, то усі "за" двом руками…
Було б гарно зробити таке з
громадськістю обговорення.
Волонтери сподіваються,
що будь-які зміни статусу АТО
не обмежать доступу до лінії розмежування.
Адже в багатьох населених пунктах
допомогу населенню,
а це здебільшого літні люди, майже щодня надають лише волонтери.
Дуже складна ситуація зараз на непідконтрольній території.
На жаль, ані національні, ані міжнародні організації
повноцінно не можуть допомогти людям, які там залишилися.
В підконтрольних Україні населених пунктах
ситуація менш критична.
Для жителя Слов’янська Юрія АТО стало вже другою війною в його житті.
Перша - Афганістан.
Досі лікує отриману там контузію.
Який би законопроект не затвердила Верховна Рада,
це не повинно призвести до збільшення масштабів воєнних дій,
вважають жителі прифронтових регіонів.